UN rights chief Michelle Bachelet calls for talks...
...to defuse growing tensions in Venezuela.
Reports indicate Venezuelan security forces killed 20 people...
...and detained 350 during protests against President Nicolas Maduro.
In the US, President Trump's former campaign adviser, Roger Stone,...
...was arrested on multiple criminal charges...
...stemming from the special counsel's probe into Russian interference...
...in the 2016 election.
Lawmakers in Greece voted to rename the Republic of Macedonia to "North Macedonia"...
...in exchange for lifting their veto on the nation of Macedonia's...
...entrance into the European Union,...
...settling a 27-year naming dispute between the two countries.
In Myanmar, a human rights investigator calls for the army chief to be prosecuted...
...for what the investigator called genocide against the Rohingya Muslim minority.
Finally from Qatar,...
...the government agreed to pay 20 million dollars in humanitarian aid to Gaza,...
...after Hamas rejected Qatari payments to impoverished government workers...
...living on the coastal strip.